sometimes films scare us sometimes they
move us to tears and sometimes they have
us laughing our butts off there's a
reason we love movies so much and it has
everything to do with a well-crafted
scene these are just a few cinematic
scenes that are practically perfect in
every way
the 1996 slasher film screen just one of
the many horror classics conceived by
Wes Craven was it once a love letter to
horror films as well as an effective
addition to the genre in its own right
no please don't kill me mr. Ghostface I
want to be the sequel set in a small
town with a history of tragic murders
the film centers on Sidney Prescott a
seemingly normal teen who starts getting
mysterious phone calls as she and her
friends are stalked by an unknown entity
known as ghost face before Sidney even
appears there is a link the opening
scene featuring drew Barrymore as Casey
Becker a teenager enjoying a night at
home when she starts getting some
unsettling phone calls at first
Casey is unfazed by these odd calls
assuming the person on the other end of
the phone is simply playing a Ruth prank
but before long she starts getting
nervous and once she sees her gutted
boyfriend posed in her backyard her
panic intensifies as her parents arrive
home at the end of the evening the
camera zooms in on her body hanging from
a tree on the property finally cutting
to the opening credits and capping off a
perfect encapsulation of both Cravens
vision and the horror genre
despite initially flopping at the box
office Frank Darabont's magnum opus The
Shawshank Redemption went on to become
one of the most beloved films of the
20th century even earning a spot on AFIS
top 100 list telling the story of Andy
Dufresne a wrongfully imprisoned man
serving two consecutive life sentences
at the Shawshank State Penitentiary the
film paints the grimmest possible
picture of prison life
Andy is brutalized every single day
until he figures out a scheme where he
can help financially manage the prison
as well as lend a hand to his fellow
inmates with their money troubles the
signature scene of the entire film is
the moment when Andy escapes from the
prison through a rock tunnel that took
nearly 20 years to build as he emerges
from the tunnel which is filled with
human waste and filth he stands clean
and victorious in the rain basking in a
hard-fought victory the audience feels
right along with him
[Music]
it's a perfect moment of human triumph
and Darabont created a completely
unforgettable image that will continue
striking an emotional chord and viewers
for years to come
adapting the Lord of the Rings series
comprised of three novels by JRR tolkien
was no easy feat but clearly one man was
up to the job Peter Jackson who used his
home country of New Zealand as the
stand-in for Tolkien's middle-earth the
film's are critical in commercial
smashes with the final installment The
Return of the King winning a whopping 11
Oscars in the first of the three films
the Fellowship of the Ring Frodo
a timid and inexperienced Hobbit of the
Shire embarks on his long journey to
destroy the One Ring that can control
the entire world during his journey with
the fellowship of nine made up of
hobbits men elves dwarves and wizards
alike the group needs to cross through
the dangerous mines of Moria home to
ancient monsters that lurk far
underground when they encounter a Balrog
an enormous demon made a fire all hope
seems lost until the powerful wizard
Gandalf sacrifices himself to get Frodo
and the rest of the Fellowship to safety
how foolish with still impressive
special effects an ideal action set
piece and strong performances across the
board
it's no wonder that
has become part of the cultural lexicon
thanks to director Quentin Tarantino's
vision of a nonlinear gangster fairytale
1994's pulp fiction is regarded as one
of the best films of not just the 1990s
but the back half of the 20th century
with an all-star cast that includes John
Travolta uma Thurman samuel l.jackson
ving rhames Bruce Willis Christopher
Walken and Tim Roth the film follows
several different stories as they
eventually converge with the entire plot
happening out of order as well as
beginning and ending at the exact same
point during a diner robbery though the
film is filled with plenty of
unforgettable scenes the most memorable
is arguably Mia Wallace's overdose and
the aftermath that follows Wallace
played by Thurman misidentifies Vegas
drugs after an evening out and promptly
snorts them after rushing and
unconscious Mia to his dealers house
Vincent ends up stabbing her in the
heart with an adrenaline-filled
hypodermic needle to revive her
[Applause]
between the ensuing insanity that takes
place over Mia's still body and
Thurman's reaction to the needle this
scene is shot and written so perfectly
that you almost feel like you're a part
of the action a great opening can
perfectly set the tone for a film and
few are as famous as the sequence that
opens Steven Spielberg's jaws the
classic horror movie that made millions
of people suddenly reconsider taking a
dip in the ocean the film itself which
is considered one of the best movies of
all time starred Richard Dreyfuss and
Roy Scheider as a marine biologist and
police chief trying to take down a
man-eating giant white shark that is
terrorizing a resort town in New England
and though they're ultimately successful
the shark takes several lives in the
process thanks to an often unreliable
mechanical shark on set Spielberg ended
up not showing his toothy antagonist in
many scenes creating a Hitchcock esque
thriller where the main villains mere
presence of vocht fear this is perfectly
displayed in the opening scene at
a party on the beach a young girl and
her boyfriend take a swim during which
they are both attacked and the girl is
eaten by the shark by filming crucial
parts of the scene from the Sharks
perspective and using menacing and now
iconic music by John Williams Spielberg
takes a less-is-more approach to
creating this unforgettable scene one of
David Fincher's most highly regarded
films 1995's 7 is a classically dark and
twisted thriller from the acclaimed
director as well as one of his first big
hits starring Morgan Freeman and Brad
Pitt the film centers on two detectives
mills and Somerset's tracking a violent
and creative serial killer who taunts
police by leaving his victims and
deliberate arrangements meant to evoke
the seven deadly sins with each crime
carefully covered up and meticulously
planned the detectives have no leads
until John Doe arrives at the police
station covered in blood to confess doe
then leads both detectives to a remote
spot in the desert to show them his
final crime revealing that he has been
guilty of the sin of envy leading into
murder Mills pregnant wife Tracy and
presenting Mills with Tracy's head in a
box
in response and enraged Mills shoots
dough representing wrath and doing
exactly what doe wants the scene with
its sepia toned color scheme tense music
and impeccable performances is a
masterclass and thrillers especially
since the audience never even sees the
contents of the box we don't need to in
fact the scene is better and more
gut-wrenching with just a mental image
the final moments of the usual suspects
the 1995 neo-noir mystery film starring
Kevin Spacey as verbal Kent one of the
sole survivors of a shootout led by a
notorious crime boss named Keyser söze
are regarded as one of the best twist
endings in film history the script
focuses almost entirely on Kent's
recollection of the events preceding the
film which involves a group of gangsters
attempting to pull off a complicated
heist in order to get revenge on the
NYPD only to be foiled by Sosa who seems
more like an urban legend than a real
person
as detectives frantically try to figure
out which person in the story could
possibly be so saying Kent's bail is
posted and leaves the police station and
as he does his physicality completely
changes his limp goes away and his
non-functioning hands suddenly works
back at the station the detectives
realized that Kent was Keyser söze the
entire time
but they're too late he's already
escaped greatest trick the devil ever
pulled was convincing the world he
didn't exist no matter how many times
you've seen the film the ending still
completely works especially once you can
look back at all the clues to film laid
throughout to lead viewers to solve the
mystery themselves Christopher Nolan
rebooted the Batman franchise to rave
reviews in 2005 with Batman Begins but
that was nothing compared to 2008's The
Dark Knight widely regarded as one of
the best films of the decade as well as
the gold standard that future superhero
movies would strive for Nolan cast Heath
Ledger then mainly known for art house
dramas and teenage romantic comedies as
the Joker to play opposite Christian
Bale's Batman and though the casting was
initially controversial the bet paid off
handsomely
tragically ledger passed away in January
of 2008 before the film's the summer
release but his performance in the film
remains one of the best of all time
there are almost too many incredible
scenes featuring Ledger to narrow them
down to one but one of his best occurs
when he crashes a high-society gala to
torment Harvey Dent terrorizing guests
and throwing glasses of champagne with
reckless abandon the scene is a perfect
encapsulation of chaos on any scale
whether that means committing murder or
simply making a mess as the Joker
traverses the party cackling as he eats
off random trays and explains his
disfigured face now I'm always fine
we'll fight you
I like that what's left to say about the
original Star Wars one of the most
influential and beloved films of all
time the story of Luke Skywalker a young
Jedi who must confront the Galactic
Empire alongside the virtuous Rebel
Alliance is one of the most important
movies ever made its success spawned a
universe of sequels and spin-offs
creating an entire industry the first
film released in the series a new hope
made worldwide stars out of Mark Hamill
who portrayed Skywalker along with
co-stars Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher
the film's final battle scene the trench
run at the Death Star is among the most
famous in a film arguably filled with
iconic moments and it's easy to see why
director George Lucas and his crew used
mostly practical effects to create a
stunning 15 minute sequence during which
Luke at a squad of Alliance pilots
attacked the Death Star
eventually blowing the fortress-like
ship to smithereens by bombing an
exhaust port tense thrilling and
victorious it's Star Wars at its very
best one of the most famous directors in
history Alfred Hitchcock is responsible
for some of the most famous and
unforgettable scenes in all of film
arguably led by that infamous shower
scene in psycho as Marion crane a young
woman who stops at the Bates Motel Janet
Leigh seems to be the hero of the story
but in a perfect subversion of
expectations Marion has stabbed to death
by an unseen attacker while taking a
shower at the motel
[Music]
[Applause]
the scene which has no score or music
until the murder focuses tightly on LY
which only increases the audience's
sense of dread when they see a shadowy
figure through the shower curtain the
camera then lingers on Lee's body
eventually contrasting her open eye with
the opened drain allowing for a sense of
symmetry this 3-minute scene which
contains only 45 seconds of action
remains one of the gold standards at the
horror genre so much so that an entire
documentary about it
7850 - was released in 2017 offering
viewers a whole new insight into this
masterful cinematic moment check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]